michel fize sociologue éditorialistes et
arte france michel fize ravi de vous
retrouver ce samedi avec nous sur ce
plateau alors on dit tous les jours se
suivent et ne se ressemblent pas en tout
cas à paris on a plus ou moins
l'impression que les familles se
ressemblent ça fait des mois maintenant
qu'on assiste à ces manifestations on va
d'abord par les seins de 7 cette
revendication dénoncé le pass annie
terre on a un peu l'impression que c'est
une histoire sans fin
oui je crois que la seule certitude dans
cette affaire c'est que nous n'avons pas
la vérité d'hier n'est pas la vérité
d'aujourd'hui on parlait des enfants il
ya un instant souvenons nous il ya un an
et demi on disait que les les enfants
n'étaient ni contaminés ni contaminants
et puis on découvre que non seulement
c'est faux mais qu'ils sont très
contaminant et peuvent être contaminés
voilà je ne reviens pas sur l'histoire
du masque le masque était inutile et qui
devient de plus en plus obligatoire et
dans des lieux de plus en plus nombreux
c'est vrai que nous sommes allés de
d'erreurs en erreurs
d'approximations en approximations
d'incohérences en incohérence avec des
mensonges a quelquefois ici ou là mais
surtout je crois beaucoup d'incertitudes
on a fait du pilotage à vue voilà
jusqu'à ce fameux pass sanitaire
inquiets chaud beaucoup les esprits
parce que encore une fois c'est une
restriction d'une liberté fondamentale 1
celle d'aller et de venir de se réunir à
sa guise avec qui l'on veut et où l'on
veut et quand une restriction devient
permanente ce qui est de plus en plus le
cas eh bien on comprend qu'il y ait une
protestation au nom des libertés qui
caractérise notre démocratie alors on
vous parliez de la vaccination des
enfants là dessus le gouvernement avance
prudemment mais a donné un calendrier
les enfants âgés de 5 à 11 ans pourront
aller se faire vacciner à partir du 20
décembre
je crois que ça reste quand même
facultatif en tout cas pour l'instant
pourquoi la vaccination des enfants
c'est un sujet si sensible
je crois qu'on revient aux doutes
concernant les vaccins d'une manière
générale on ne sait pas
ce qui va se passer dans quelques années
une fois qu'on aura eu 7 cette
succession de vaccination qui vous avez
un petit exemple depuis hier matin j'en
suis à ma cinquième vaccination depuis
un an et demi en comptant les deux
vaccinations contre contre la grippe et
bien c'est vrai que j'ai quand même
quelques craintes a considéré que nous
allons devoir être vaccinés tous les
tous les six mois on ne sait pas si le
corps adulte est capable de de supporter
des vaccinations à à répétition alors
quand aux enfants qui sont par
définition plus fragiles que les adultes
on peut comprendre qu'il y est un doute
sur d'éventuels dangers et risques à
utiliser des vaccins dont on dit falzar
en tête qu'ils sont adaptées aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aux enfants mais je crois
que là aussi on est dans la question des
libertés et des responsabilités
familiales on peut comprendre que les
parents n'ai pas envie de livrer leurs
enfants à peut-être ce qu'il considère
comme des expérimentations
médicamenteuse alors on a d'un côté des
manifestations contre le passé ni terre
contre la vaccination en général et puis
de l'autre côté on a la cinquième bague
1 ça se confirme c'est est confirmée par
le gouvernement serait même dans le pic
on a une pression hospitalière qui est
telle que le plan blanc a été activée
dans de nombreuses régions ça n'augure
rien de bon je crois que on voit bien
qu'une vague en chasse une autre un
variant en chasse une autre que les
personnes fragiles d'hier les personnes
âgées le sent moins qu'aujourd'hui les
enfants sont parmi les cibles
potentielles du virus
j'ai envie de dire bon ce que j'ai dit
aussi quelquefois ici le virus en vain
de comptes n'en fait qu'à sa tête lui il
se moque des dépenses sanitaires et eau
et autres mesures bon qu'il faut
évidemment appliqué pour nous protéger
un tant soit peu mais il sait se glisser
se modifier muté comme il faut alors je
pense que ce que ces manifestations
montre et je crois que ça ça va dans le
bon sens c'est que on ne peut pas
s'habituer on ne doit pas s'habituer à
cette situation parce qu'on entend dire
parfois de la part même de certains
spécialistes il va falloir s'habituer à
vivre avec le virus à des scores qui
revient souvent voilà mais je pense
qu'il est il est extrêmement dangereux
il faut qu'on retrouve la ville la vie
d'avant alors ça prendra peut-être un
petit peu de temps ça demandera
peut-être des moyens importants et
notamment en élargissant je dirais le
spect la vaccination au monde entier et
en particulier au continent africain qui
est pour le moment très très très très
présent tard voilà donc je pense que je
pense qu'effectivement les gens dans la
rue
ne prennent pas ce qui est décidé comme
des faits taki d'effets irréversibles
voilà je pense que ça c'est c'est
quelque chose d'important de même que
les gilets jaunes cons et qu'on a aperçu
et bien continue de développer j'ai
presque envie de dire un contre
programme au programme des candidats
présidentiels
1 il ya évidemment avec une version
économique
bon tout droit même chose pour les gilet
jaune le pouvoir d'achat une version
politique le rite référendum
d'initiative populaire qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs sous des formes plus ou moins
édulcorée chez marine le pen et cheryl
zemmour et même chez valérie pécresse
pour prendre 3 3 exemples trois exemples
significatifs
voilà donc je pense que
tout ça exprime que cette société que
l'on dit très déprimée ainsi on on se
réfère la dernière étude ipsos fondation
jean jaurès et ben reste malgré tout
vivante voilà là on a des gens debout et
qui n'acceptent pas ce qui paraît être
encore une fois l'irrémédiable
un
provisoire qui va s'éterniser
michel fize est ce que vous y croyez au
confinement semi confinement confinant
partiel on se perd un peu d'ailleurs au
niveau des mots à la rentrée je veux
dire à la rentrée janvier je pense que
le confinement
c'est une alternative extrêmement
dangereuses et d'abord politiquement
parce qu'effectivement elle pourrait
avoir des résultats sur les intentions
de vote des uns et des autres et puis
encore une fois je crois que
psychologiquement et mentalement il ya
un tel niveau de fatigue
d'usure
de dépression mais main on a beaucoup
parlé avec les enfants quand ils étaient
les adolescents confinés chez eux on en
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui on pointe les
femmes de moins de 35 ans qui serait
particulièrement exposées à tomber dans
des états de fatigue et état dépressif
donc comment est ce qu'on peut imaginer
qu'on va rajouter une mesure
forte 1 à cet état de dégradation de
santé qui est déjà à de mon point de vue
extrêmement préoccupant quand pouvons
nous imaginer une sortie de crise en jeu
par pas manié je parle bien et non pas
de la fin de ce virus parce qu'on ne
sait pas quand ce sera fini mais je
parle de toutes ces tous ces mouvements
toutes ces manifestations ce moment en
france
je pense qu'on est on est dépendant
j'allais presque envie de dire on est
esclave de ce virus qui encore une fois
n'en fait qu'à sa tête bon il nous a
inventé déjà toute une série de deux
variants plus préoccupant les uns que
les autres on en est à omikron mais bon
omicron s'il n'atteint pas sa cible
correctement va se transformer en
quelque chose qui sera peut-être plus
dangereux alors comment est-ce qu'on
peut contrarier tout ça alors c'est
certain vacciner plus
faire des rappels de doses de vaccins
bon multiplié les gestes barrière on a
eu un peu tendance à négliger c'est vrai
mais c'est un combat c'est un combat
extrêmement difficile un le virus est un
guerrier hors pair voilà ce n'est pas un
soldat de pacotille année aussi j'espère
qu'on est des guerriers michel fize en
tout cas merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau je vous rappelle que
vous êtes un sociologue l'éditorialiste
merci merci à vous